thousands of people thousands of people
lines around the block for a Monday show
and freezing freezing temperature a
crowd that is so big I could barely see
the back of the room
all right happy Monday everybody so
another government agency has concluded
that kovid came from a lab
I know and we have a photo of that lab
right here
[Laughter]
oh not that lab although reports
indicate he's still a really good boy
yeah this time the Revelation comes from
the U.S energy Department
my first thought well welcome to the
party you Clueless
sorry I was off for a few days I'm
cranky but how is this news
but also who gives a damn about what the
department of energy thinks about
anything other than energy Jay I can
hardly wait to hear what the Department
of Treasury thinks about my gastro
reflux
the news comes from the Wall Street
Journal signing a classified Intel
report recently provided to the White
House and key members of Congress
which includes George Santos
says George Santos
a revised version will be provided to
members of the squad once every word is
replaced with racist
this is all a year after the FBI
concluded the same thing that it
probably wasn't bat soup from a wet
Market
hell it wasn't even the walnut shrimp
from Panda Express
so enjoy as much bad as you want just go
easy on the breadsticks those carry
Ebola
no all right fans of breadsticks now the
people who want to downplay the news
will say that the energy Department made
its judgment with quote low confidence
which is what fox says when asked if
kill meat still works here
and the FBI's previous conclusion was
with moderate confidence low confidence
moderate confidence why not just replace
our government with a magic eight ball
and no not that eight ball
Hunter if you're watching anyway let's
let's do now admits the Wuhan lab was
leaker than Joe Biden's Underpants
we got the FBI in the energy Department
as a yes but the FBI had no comment but
promised to raid Mike lindell's house
again just for the hell of it
either way the Tide's turning towards
something we had already known and got
crap for saying so here's a former
Director of National Intelligence
you had these scientists privately in
emails conceding I don't know how this
occurs in nature from the beginning
there has never been an environmental
source for covid-19 which is why you see
all of these scientists and now
intelligence agencies backing away from
prior assessments pretty astute when
something doesn't occur in nature well
you would deem that unnatural or
man-made I mean just watch The View
[Laughter]
for insight
but the White House promises Joe's going
to get to the bottom of this
there is a variety of views in the
intelligence Community here's what I can
tell you President Biden has directed
repeatedly every element of our
intelligence Community to put effort and
resources behind getting to the bottom
of this question if we gain any further
Insider information we will share it
with Congress and we will share it with
the American people get to the bottom of
this hell Joe can barely get to the
bottom of his morning Cream of Wheat
without passing out face first into the
bowl
he can get to the bottom of stairs
that's usually when he's walking up them
fact is we've lost our faith in all
these creeps scientists included I mean
three years ago if you told me men had
vaginas I'd say uh someone never played
truth or dare
[Laughter]
[Applause]
protection but only as long as it Strays
from the truth it's the truth that's in
trouble now you remember the early days
when anyone who brought up the lab leak
was called The Conspiracy Theory Nut Job
hell this show were a bunch of nut jobs
we began to find that the wet Market
Theory fell apart and the laboratory
leak Theory got stronger they described
the spike protein right at the start of
the pandemic in this virus they just
don't point out that it's got a feature
that no other sars-like virus has ever
had in it in a sense they succeeded in
gain of function before creating a cage
for it it's absolutely mind-boggling
that they did this hmm
and that
that was 10 years ago
[Laughter]
minus six or seven maybe eight years but
that's Matt Ridley and me I'm the
handsome one laying out the lab Leak
with evidence and we got crap for it
invested pretty much anyone else who
suggested it Facebook banned mentions of
the leak all together with Zuckerberg on
the wrong side of history and Truth once
again media Outlets from The Washington
Post MSNBC to Scientific American they
either laughed off or attacked those
claims and check out these geniuses
this question about the Wuhan lab we
know that it's been debunked that this
virus was man-made or modified or
anything like that the conspiracy theory
going around that the coronavirus
originated and was perhaps man-made
inside a lab in China Dr Anthony fauci
rejected the conspiracy the coronavirus
was man-made in a lab in Wuhan China
both scientists and the US intelligence
Community agree that this coronavirus
was not man-made that is not a
possibility
with so much egg on their faces it's not
a face it's a frittata
that has eggs in it just in case you
guys don't know but how can this
surprise you the media is consistently
wronger than a waiter asking Joy Behar
if she's eating for two
remember of course they said Hunter's
laptop was misinformation turned out it
was as real as his crack habit they said
gas stoves aren't being banned under the
current proposals they will be but if I
went through every single thing that
they were wrong in from Smollett to
Covington to the p-tape cloth mats don't
say gay we'd be here till tomorrow
morning when they crack open the boxes
and unpack the Fox and Friends hosts
which is why this lab League story is
such a big deal because the media and
the Government tried to hold it back
like Eric swalwell after a cabbage
smoothie
[Laughter]
the fart show
[Applause]
and it's that cooperation which we
should all find disturbing because it's
not really cooperation it's another c
word corruption cover-up and of what
could it be that the government used the
media to smear the lab leak Theory
because they were funding the Wuhan
Institute and wanted to make sure their
hands were clean maybe maybe not still
we need to chase this story down not
only because over a million Americans
have died from coven but because maybe
we'll finally get the truth and start
holding some people if not a country
accountable and when that finally
happens the bat soup will be on me
let's welcome tonight's guests
cheese broke more stories than an
ex-wielding librarian anchor of the
story Martha McCallum
he supports recycling by sleeping in a
cardboard box founder of the
loftusparty.com Michael Lofton
he spent more time on New York streets
than hot dog carts and prostitutes
former NYPD inspector Paul Morrow
and finally she was also leaked from a
Chinese lap Foxy's contributor captive
[Applause]
Martha I want to take you back a couple
years back when we were both a bit
younger
you wouldn't know because we're both
beautiful but there are people that were
saying this was racist and if I would
steal man that argument and say okay
it's racist because the people who would
say it's from China they might be racist
about something else so they think that
that's the reason why you can't talk
about it not that it's actually from
China do you buy that do you buy the
reasoning that why we shouldn't have
talked about it no
I mean it's ridiculous you you look at
this situation right you had I mean I
think Jon Stewart was sort of a turning
point in this whole thing and when he
went on and actually said you know well
it's at the Wuhan viral virology lab is
right near where this happened it was
almost like oh my God he's singing yeah
he's saying I mean it it defies logic it
has since the beginning not to dig into
this for what it was one of the
questions that I have and I love that
you pointed out the low confidence
moderate confidence what a study yes
what does that mean exactly so they're
saying we think it came from the lab but
we have low low confidence so in other
words we know we have to say it because
we know it's all unraveling it is all
unraveling you have a study on that from
Oxford on The Masks you have the Lancet
which by the way was the number one
place that gathered up the scientists
right away and said not from the lab
yeah nothing to see here they made
everybody sign that that was Peter dazak
who was involved yes Eco Health Alliance
who was funding the in all of the
science all that money follow the money
that went to gain of function research
both here and over there so it's it's
unraveling and so now that well we have
it but we have it on low confidence but
what I it was digging for today they
won't say why yeah why did you change
your mind this is an adjustment to a
2021 dni report and so today they're
saying and leak through the Wall Street
Journal essentially they're saying well
now we think it actually might have come
to from the lab but we can't tell you
why yeah like I can tell you why it's
exactly what the scientist said to you
back then they knew there was a
structural difference in this virus that
didn't look like anything that was found
in nature right and Robert Redfield came
on my show time and time again he said
it you can't this was supercharged
that's why it kept spinning off into all
these variants so quickly that's why it
went from Lab to human and human to
human so quickly the markings were all
there but if you said it came from China
it it was like a racist Maga combination
that was instantly shut down across the
board and now it's like I said yeah you
can't complain about Chinese lawn
furniture but not their viruses Paul
Yuri uh you are a former detective and a
lawyer and an expert curler which I did
not know
um Josh Hawley is introducing
legislation to make sure all covid uh
Intel is open to the public is that
going to help at all to you what do you
see this what's the next step after all
this lawsuits that go on forever
um I think the next step should be the
following they should remember that big
black lives matter mural that they
painted down Pennsylvania Avenue like
them or not what they should paint now
is we're sorry Donald Trump yeah all
right because he said it and
ah some children you know I mean
as time goes on how many more times are
we going to say geez you know he
actually got it right yeah and this is
really I think the stand I mean we can't
forget seven million people globally
have died from this thing so I don't
know how much Intel is actually going to
come out you know there are layers of
parm layers by the way the low
confidence medium confidence stuff all
those of terms of Art in intelligence
and you know what they really mean uh
we'd like to tell you but we really
don't think we should tell you and my
boss hasn't really wanted to get out and
so they hide behind jargon as we've said
in the past the more jargon there is in
anything Federal the less likely you are
to get to the actual truth yeah that is
true yeah
[Applause]
yo Michael whenever I uh I tell people
hey if you ever want to see what pink
looks like in 20 years check out Michael
Loftus
for being open to my lifestyle
where do you see this going it's
infuriating yeah like our government's
way too big like way too big what is the
Department of energy even doing even
near this like last time don't we need
like like lower gas prices yeah
there's spills everywhere in the
department of energies like the
Scooby-Doo gang look into the Wu hand
yeah
anybody with half a brain this came from
the lab yeah and like the department
like was the FBI just like just too busy
it's like hey we've got kidnappings to
fake we got January 6th to do we got
Russian emails to make yeah the
department of energy is like zoinks
yeah I love the fact that you're the
only person who uses the word zoinks
yeah but I do want to give a big shout
out to the to the Chinese propaganda
people for for getting that much mileage
out of bat suit I know I know you know
they had a meeting and they're like we
got to blame it on something I got uh
snake fritters I got bat soup I got uh
Cobra noodles who go back one do you
know what's funny we you're on to
something we need to apologize to the
wet markets yes right the wet markets
that's like you know what imagine
another country attacking our farmers
markets right farmers markets sound
great oh you got fresh fruit well wet
markets are chess farmers markets with
bats
yeah and it's it's amazing yeah I don't
know if they're exactly like that
the weather
they call because they're hosing on the
blood because right
yes that's right vitamins that's how I
Stay Alive cat
from the blood of wet markets you know
do you think it's wrong for me cat when
I think about all those people that made
fun of us to want to murder them
with mockery
[Laughter]
you know what I mean it's like I want to
take uh I have some names of people
here's the thing I think that oh it's
bad when they start making lists yes go
ahead I'll look for my list I actually
think that even if this they didn't come
out and admit this which I agree it was
always pretty obvious that this is what
happened the way that they treated
people for just asking questions isn't
okay I mean have you ever like we all
know somebody in our lives somehow maybe
it's a family member maybe it's like a
friend's boyfriend something that's like
cuckoo conspiracy like yeah totally like
you know like the moon's not real 5G
made my son gay whatever stuff like that
yeah and and you're like how did this
person get like this yeah and sometimes
it's meth yeah
but other times it's like if if even
asking a simple question where you
actually have many legitimate reasons to
believe that it's true will get you shut
down and I mean band off of Facebook
people you know mocked publicly like
you're not welcome in polite society
when you're not welcome polite Society
where is you're gonna go deeper into
stuff of course everybody else wants to
talk to go underground can you really go
gay from 5G because I'm real I'm really
too heterosexual talk to my um uncle's
friend's girlfriend
all right I have a list of names I'd
like to work through but I guess we have
to go to break all right you're lucky
this time Tom Nichols a poorva
mandevilly Jill phillipovic and apple
bomb and Nicole Wallace hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else